alors steevy vous êtes désormais
comédien fait que la ville est bien joli
choix qui vous le dirai l'art de la
comédie c'est l'art de mentir
nous allons donc faire une interview
mensonge c'est très compliqué vous devez
répondre steevy exactement le contraire
de ce que vous pensez d'accord d'accord
il ya du piège où je sens comment ça se
passe avec l'udc est plutôt très mal
vraiment très très mal c'est la cata tu
les as bon il a compris le principe ont
déjà une chose reste on regarde ça va
tomber la même si vie ce que vous avez
été obligé de coucher pour avoir le rôle
oui j'ai couché par abarth et rollin
avec ma main droite avec qui avec ma
main droite avec sa maman qui est des
monos sexuelle et stevie ça vous fait
quoi que des gens payent plus de 40
euros pour venir vous voir sur la scène
d'un théâtre ça je me contrefous
vraiment rien à [ __ ] chacun sa bourse
stevie imaginer qu'un jour vous marier
que vous ayez des enfants et que votre
fils viennent vous voir et vous annonce
qu'il est hétérosexuel vous réagiriez
comment très mal très mal et je vous ai
déjà fait l'amour et bourrique et stevie
vue si ça fait la bouffe avec brit et
enfin en tout cas elle est à côté de moi
à à michel demande qui est bourriquet
michel humez chien en peluche et
expliquer qui est beau piqué alors
bourrique et c'est une petite tenue sont
fait une grosse pub us que j'ai depuis
l'âge de 6 ans destiné au départ c'est
marrant mais ce qui est bien et est
pratiquement plus connu que moi vous
riquez à chaque fois peut-être veille il
ya des gens dans la rue alors comment va
vous dire ça c'est là c'est le cri
comment va vous laisse bruit qu'elles
élaborent des bonheurs divers
stevie avez-vous menti au cours de cette
interview
non le mystère c'est bien ça
labrosse est humaine